welcome to this video playing horse the
white horse the white okay hi 30 years
old Phoenix Arizona USCF to 105 m you
can tell that to some [ __ ] but you are
not a USCF to 105 player that's simply
not possible to get to four and five
minutes chest with 21 use the usf but ok
let's see what what happens idea to even
higher higher ratings and his top rating
so let's check this is just for fun here
top 5 million rating was 25 top one
minute and it was 26 yeah I can tell
that to some more on Jan you need to be
a pretty strong player to get to this
rating and even higher and 221 USCF is
not enough ok not so important playing
them the kind of Z my variation here and
come and move all with v6 and ok just
developing
and see what black is trying to do with
this king ok it's castling short so
should I go nite g3 or maybe I can
cancel first Bishop g5 was also a good
move actually ok the berry yeah this I
mean it's normal but it's in this
specific position a very slow approach
yeah this is some very debatable the f 5
squares very weak now yeah okay cannot
take it anyway because I g5 until the
night will arrive on f5
ok
that's an interesting IDM so g3 and f4
or how should I proceed and it's not not
so clear can even take and play c5
ok this is also possible how to
determine what what's best really
okay let's let's take it here get rid of
them go on weakness here that's very
tough to play take
you
can I'd like to prevent Nigel form not
i'm not sure what what's best here
really talk too tough to determine okay
i'll hear this even g4y can just take
it's both go with interesting I'd okay
times limited
okay i will play at Roy we can each for
should be three and so on
yeah maybe you can grip on d4 but it's
very very risky maybe you can do that
but it's even Bishop c4 to d5 m94 is
insane but maybe I'm blacks beyond this
point already
ok
poor chap that's so very very
complicated huh that'sthat's my that is
clear maybe I should have taken and play
Bishop d forwards it's really really
tricky take here now Quinn Texas to know
this check I mean isn't this entirely
unplayable because the Rue cage weren't
comin I thought but he's for proving me
wrong he played it
threatening um time warning yeah
threatening bed actually didn't he
didn't react to the threat takes only
three I just take with the king
as it's super difficult game I mean I
had to have my doubts about what he did
but it's so complicated how to tell okay
check
you're my position is selecting a bit in
harmony but should that should be okay
check check check check black resigns
yeah i mean i really think that around
here it should be really excellent for
what around here but it's it's so
complicated can always go terribly wrong
in blitz and that's metal precision the
computer wants to go h4 here for example
could be a good idea really play this
first and only then go to f5 some its
may be more precise nie Dage five was a
good defense at first term very
complicated I mean and I know one thing
I wouldn't ever have considered to grab
them but it it's maybe not losing
immediately how the computers now a
computer now gives why the wind actually
with rook hmm very strong move probably
intending to to switch the rook over
yeah well this my idea was this it's
probably also not too bad yeah it's also
winning four wide according to the comp
yes why wasn't I wasn't entirely wrong
about
about things that's reassuring um queen
bee three though seems to be stronger
yeah now and now I think it's a win
right because Roxy 6 is tough to prevent
the problem is if you go there for
example i go here and break through him
that's too much here now what is white
is winning here very very tough game ok
thanks for watching